Samantha B for those who are wondering
is was speaking of known speaking of no
talent
nothing do we have that let's port let's
pull that up from the soundboard who
Samantha bee she plans an anti White
House Correspondents Dinner and it's
called the not I believe it's called the
not not the White House Correspondents
Dinner so I don't feel so bad about my
lazy my lazy work in the humor
Department earlier like when churches
put all like I like like alternatives to
Super Bowl so you have to see Janet
Jackson's tits
let's save the world from the Jews you
know the white oh yeah proceeds go to
the Committee to Protect Journalists did
you hear that that's adorable
Samantha be think she's press she's not
press and she's not funny and I know
that's an attack of people will use if
they disagree with us oh my gosh if
you're if you're a comedian you have to
be funny no I think Jon Stewart was very
funny I think Rob Riggle I think Stephen
Colbert I think ed Helms I think a lot
of these people who were who were on The
Daily Show before were very funny I
think Bill Maher can be funny I think
Kathleen Madigan is as far to the left
as comedians can be is exceptionally
funny so and we've been very consistent
about that if you go and watch the show
or any of our commentary back when Jon
Stewart was still doing his gig very
funny Samantha bee I hate you Samantha
bee is offensively unfunny I only
reserve the word offensive for people
who are that unfunny and her and Trevor
no it was one of those things where you
saw them and they they got their own The
Daily Show they got their own choice
you're going really because everyone
knew they were the weakest link if Rob
Riggle were to have a show tomorrow
everyone here would that make sense
right you say okay Rob riggles very
close isn't and by the way when you're
talking about protecting the Committee
to Protect Journalists this was written
about at the Washington Post and it was
written it was like written as an
invitation to a-listers like so is
anyone going to the the White House
Correspondents all the top fails two
talents gonna be there yes like me the
writer at Washington Post here's my
resume
1966 so Samantha bee she's taking it
upon herself to protect to protect
journalists has has thrown her name
amongst them and will be protesting what
else is new protesting the White House
Correspondents Dinner which should be
one time where conservatives and
liberals can get together laugh at each
other it's a long-standing tradition and
Donald Trump even showed up before when
Barack Obama roasted him and he handled
it in good fun well as good fun as
Donald Trump can handle it I mean we're
at a point now with this how much more
annoying can Hollywood get hey Tony you
going to that submit the bees not the
White House Correspondents Dinner Oh
rath I don't have time for that kind of
ballyhoo anymore come on
could be fun yeah really think she's
cute well when you put it that way
woman atone berth to earth I don't live
to regret it you gotta take advantage
who knows how long this Hollywood
meltdowns gonna last
could be
[Music]
Hollywood is everywhere they can't hold
back they have to share all that thing
the lesson gender is added again a gay
scene is in every
you
award seasons extra crass celebrities
kissing ass so look I got a feeling
Samantha P undoubtedly will suck
horribly
black lives matter women's rights
hashtag Oscars are so white everywhere
you go in all-female oceans eight Mindy
aquafina Kate I already know it
Hollywood is ruining everything
Ghostbusters wife
it's not a joke down it's really [ __ ]
scary
[Music]
oh look at that Samantha B brought
things that she is funny but she just
sucks but she just sucks but she just
[Music]
hey if you like this video subscribe by
clicking the button that says subscribe
if you're not aware of it now there's no
way you're learning the Internet at this
point I'm not going to help you but this
was clipped from my daily show available
exclusively to lotto with credit.com
slash mug club members of your student
military or veteran entering that promo
code it's less than $6 a month and you
get daily content no more clips Plus
this hand etched mug
oh I just when I feel it I got a chill
like on the inside